So, sorry for the delay we will go to the today's topic straight away which is Declining
applications in computer vision. So, as many of you might be knowing that one of the most
important architecture that is used for the computer vision task are the convolutional
neural network architecture. So, I believe up till now you have seen
feed forward neural network architecture as which I have discussed in the last class and
possibly you have also done some programming with the feed forward neural network architecture.
So, today we are going to first discuss the convolutional neural network architecture
and then we are going to discuss how to solve a different computer vision problem using
this convolutional neural network architecture. So, in order to motivate the convolutional
neural network architecture let us first discuss a few properties of the image data ok. So,
the first property that I want to discuss. So, I just want to mention that these properties
of the image data are important for understanding the image and these are also specific to image.
So, other kind of data. So, for example, if you take some sort of a demographic data or
if you take time series data or those kind of things all these properties may not be
present ok. So, what are these properties? So, the first property is the topology property
ok. So, what is the topology property? So, what is the topology property? So, the topology
property says that so, suppose so, you can so, here you can see in the left this image
right. So, this image you can think of it as a grid like this ok, a grid like this ok,
where each of this pixels has a value let us say for simplicity we can say that this
is between 0 to 255 ok that is how. So, it can be slightly more complicated, but that
is how it is stored ok. So, now, the first thing is that the pixels
in an image are like aligned in this way in a grid or they are placed in a grid. So,
what does the grid have? It has a size ok. So, for example, it may be let us say 1024
into 768 let us say this is the image size I am just saying I am saying some number.
So, basically the column indices are varying from 1 to 1024 and the row indices here are
varying from 1 to 768 in this particular image ok. So, every pixel so, the image data size
is going to be 1024 into 768 ok. Now, whatever this particular size is that many 18 bit values
or 1 byte values are going to be there in this image ok and now for these that many
values they are not arranged in one row ok. So, they are not arranged like this that you
start with 1 here and then you go to 1024 into 768 it is not like that it is arranged
in a grid in this manner and which pixel is close to which other pixel that information
is important ok and that information is called the topology of the pixels.
So, a particular pixel will have some neighboring pixel. So, for example, this pixel will have
a neighboring pixel. So, let me just take another color here maybe yeah. So, this pixel will
have this pixel as a neighbor the blue pixel this pixel as a neighbor this pixel as a neighbor
and this pixel as a neighbor. So, these are called 4 neighbors ok. So, up down left right
ok. So, 4 neighbors ok there are going to be also 8 neighbors sometimes. So, this this
this and this. So, up down left right and also the 4 corners ok. So, they will include the
8 neighbors of a particular pixel. What is the pixel? The pixel is the center pixel ok.
So, this particular formation where each pixel has some neighborhood this is called the topology
of the pixels. So, this is the first important property of images which is not there in other
types of data ok. Now, the second class of important properties
are what are called translation invariance or scale invariance ok. So, what is the translation
invariance? You see this particular. So, you see the top row of images here ok. So, the
top row of images here they have or or even even more let us say let us take these images
ok. They are describing as a human being we know that they are describing the same thing
which is there is a can of some cold drinks some some sort of a drinks which is lying
in a grass right, but if you see from the image point of view in this image it is somewhat
towards the top side in this image may be somewhere else it has come ok.
So, what is happening is the image is translating ok. So, the position of the object is moving.
So, the the image is translating, but the topology of many of the pixel most of the
pixels the important pixels or the pixels around this particular object let us say they
may be same they may be remaining same. Another thing is if you look at let us say let us
say let me erase the things. So, let us say if you look at this this image may be this
image and then this image right. So, again maybe there is also a little bit of translation,
but more importantly you see there is a zooming in ok. So, the camera is zooming in to the
object ok. So, the object itself has become bigger progressively from here to here then
here to here and so on and so forth ok. So, this is called the scale invariant ok.
So, so both of these are invariance properties ok, then there may be other invariances for
example, lightning or contrast. So, here you can see it is the same thing, but the lighting
is a bit different. So, the glass is looking slightly more yellow in this whereas, in this
one the glass is looking slightly more green and so on and so forth ok ok.
So, these are some of the properties of the image data and why are we discussing this
properties? We are discussing this properties because whatever neural network we design
ok, we have to design by keeping these properties in mind. So, that is the important thing that
we have to design the neural network by keeping these properties in mind ok.
So, how can we do that? So, just a brief description. So, computer vision is the field of artificial
intelligence that focuses on enabling machines to interpret and understand visual information
which is that if I give you a image you should be your program. So, artificial intelligence
program that you design which is the field of computer vision it should be able to interpret
and understand the information that is there in that image.
So, put in layman's terms if I give this particular image let us say it should be able to say
that this image is something like a coke can or a cold drink can which is there on a grass
or this image if I give it should be able to say that it is a football on a grass ok.
So, that is the job of computer vision. So, that is what you are going to do ok.
Now, in order to achieve that what do you have to do? You have to do two broad categories
of task what is that? The first one is that you have to develop neural network models
for different application ok and second is you have to also develop data sets and algorithms
for the application ok. Now, in this particular lecture we will mostly focus on the first
one because the second one is already given in all probability you will not be developing
when you are applying a new thing. There is a high chance that you will not be developing
new data sets or you will not be developing new application, but you will be developing
new model for the application as the case ok.
Now, so as I mentioned this particular model will be called convolutional neural network
model as opposed to feed forward neural network model. Now, in feed forward neural network
what happens? So, any neural network you know every neural network is organized as layer.
So, this is one layer. So, let us say layer 1 ok and every layer has some activation right.
Now, this will be layer 2. So, this is I am talking about feed forward neural network
ok. Now, in in feed forward neural network every like every pixel is connected to every
other pixel ok and this connections carry weightage as you know and then there is a summation
etcetera ok. In convolutional neural network the layer is there ok. So, if I were to try
and erase these things ok. So, the layers are there. So, this is layer 1, this is layer
2 ok, but two things are happening. First is that these layers are arranged in the topographic
format ok. So, now, if I if I were to try and let me erase this and if I were to try
and say. So, this is let us say layer 1 ok. So, this is layer 1, this is going to be layer
2 ok. So, this is how it is going to be of course, there will be activation ok, but there
is another thing that the connections are now not fully connected ok and we will come
to why the connections are not fully connected, but they are actually in the form of a convolution
operation ok. So, what is the convolution operation ok?
Convolution operation involves a kernel ok. Now what happens? So, kernel is basically instead
of earlier there was one weight per connection. Now, the kernel there will be just one kernel
between each layer. So, there will be one kernel here ok. Using this kernel we will
do the convolution operation from this layer and calculate the layer 2 from layer 1 using
the convolution operation ok. Now, this kernel is something like this ok. So, this is the
kernel ok, this is the kernel ok. What is it? It is a grid of weight. So, so this is
the input input means input image. So, just like your input image is there in a grid.
So, this is a 3 by 3 grid your kernel or the weights are also arranged in a grid ok. So,
in the convolution layer the input, the output and the learnable weights which are defined
using this kernel ok, all of them are arranged in a grid ok. So, this is the first thing
ok. So, this kernels are also sometimes called filters ok.
Now, what this kernel does is this kernel gets overlaid on a grid. So, let me see here
ok. So, let me first show you what overlaying mean in this thing. So, you can see that this
blue thing is a kernel ok. So, the blue thing is a kernel. Now, the pink thing is a kernel
ok and it is getting overlaid on top of the pixel ok. So, the kernel is getting overlaid
on top of the pixel. So, this is what is meant by overlaying ok.
Let us come back to our slides ok. So, now suppose you are overlaying this particular
kernel ok let me erase this. So, suppose you are overlaying this particular kernel on this
input, then what will the convolution operation do? Convolution operation will multiply the
corresponding numbers with each other ok. So, let me see how that goes. So, this is
the calculation ok. So, this kernel is getting overlaid on top of this input. So, 3 is getting
multiplied by minus 1. So, this is 3 and this is minus 1, they are getting multiplied ok.
2 is getting multiplied by 0 and so on and so forth ok. So, all these multiplications
are happening ok. Now, after this all these are added together
ok, all these numbers are added together and then you come up with a particular number
ok. What is the position where this number will be put? The position where this will
be put in the output is in the center of this whole overlay process ok. So, this overlay
process will happen many many times because in a practical case your input will be very
big, your kernel will be very small as I was describing earlier. So, this is one particular
overlay of the kernel ok. There can be another overlay of the kernel which is something like
this ok. There can be another overlay of the kernel which is something like this ok. So,
the kernel is the same ok, but 3 different overlays on the image. So, this is the image
ok. So, let me go back to blue ok. This is the image and these are all kernels ok, this
is one kernel, this is another kernel. So, these are not different kernels, but the overlay
of the same kernel in different position ok. I hope. So, this is the crucial thing to be
clear ok. So, that is what we have written here that output over the centered pixel is
going to be summation over all the pixels in the kernel ok W p times pixel p ok. Now,
the area on which this overlay happens, this particular area of the image where the overlay
is happening, this area will be called the receptive field sorry the this area will be
called the receptive field ok. So, this area will be called the receptive field ok. So,
this is the idea. Now, these kernels and convolutions have traditionally been used in image processing
many many times ok. So, let me show. So, these are some of the operations ok. So, let me
show some tradition and kernel ok. So, this is a very traditionally used Gaussian blur
kernel ok. So, so this performs the blurring operation blurring operation means what? Suppose
you can see on the left this is your input image, on the right this is a blurred image.
So, blurred image what happens? Basically if you see very carefully some of the boundaries
the object boundaries they have become a little bit fuzzy ok. So, the object boundaries have
become a little bit fuzzy ok. Now, this particular kernel does the blurring
operation. Why does this problem kernel does the blurring operation? Because if you see
what this kernel does is it has a weightage of 1 in the neighboring pixels and the weightage
of 4 in the center pixel ok. So, it is giving equal weightage to the value of the center
pixel ok. So, let us say center pixel is red ok. Maybe top pixel is also red, this side
pixel left side pixel is also red, but let us say right and down pixels are blue. So,
what will happen? This will have 6 parts red and 2 parts blue ok. So, the value the value
of this pixel has now changed a bit and hence you see the edges have become a little bit
blurred ok. So, this is one thing. Opposite thing is this particular kernel you see it
is a sharpening kernel. So, what is happening? It is giving a high importance to the center
pixel and also deducting whatever is there in the pixel surrounding it. So, for example,
if I just erase this. So, suppose center pixel is a little bit combination of red and blue
ok. What will happen is and let us say all the pixels in the side are blue, then what
it will do is it will reduce the blue intensity of this pixel. So, it will very very sharply
define the edges. So, here is an example. So, the left image is the normal image and
the right image is the sharpened version of the image ok. And this is a much more intensified
version of the sharpening kernel. So, I am just giving you. So, these numbers inside
the kernel right now are manually chosen, but when you design your neural network you
do not have to manually choose these numbers. These numbers will automatically be lured
ok. I am just telling these particular kernels to give you an intuition as to how the kernel
operates on the entire image ok ok. So, now, here are some more. So, this is a vertical
line detector. So, if your image has a vertical line this can be detected, this is a horizontal
line detector, this is a corner detector and so on and so forth. And you can work it out
and you can see why these are all these kinds of detectors ok ok.
Now, what do convolutional neural networks do? So, first of all we have to understand
that each layer of a convolutional neural network performs a some type of a convolution
ok. Now, what does this convolution do? The convolution create some visual features out
of the image ok. So, maybe it is detecting edges ok. So, edges are some visual features.
So, from this particular cat it may be detecting some some edges let us say here, here, here,
maybe it will detect some edges for the stripes of the cat and so on and so forth ok. So,
these are some of the edges ok. Now, what you will get at the end of this edge detection
is another image which will only have the edges ok. So, I will show you a example in
a minute ok. Now, if you give that particular image to another convolutional layer, maybe
it will be able to detect shapes ok. What are shapes? Shapes are basically you know these
are formed by combination of different edges. So, maybe it will detect a circular shape here,
maybe it will detect the eye shape here ok, maybe it will detect the nose shape here and
so on and so forth ok. So, this is a thought experiment that cat has let us say. So, you
have to understand that this particular image is that for a cat ok that is the task. So,
how will you understand this? You will understand that there are two eyes which are in certain
positions in relation to one another ok plus maybe there is a cat fur texture ok. Now,
eyes are maybe a dark circle inside another circle ok and circle may be a particular combination
of edge detectors, maybe this is a very some sort of a approximation of a circle. So, so
this kind of 8 edge detectors may be used to get a approximation of a circle ok. Similarly,
fur may be a certain kind of pattern ok that may be detected by certain kind of kernel
ok. So, what convolutional neural networks do is they build up these features ok. So,
that is the key idea ok. So, primary ideas let the neural network learn
which kernels are the most useful. So, as you learn a kernel it will detect some kind
of a features you do not know what features. So, it could be edges it could be something
else ok, but whatever it is the training process will ensure that these features are useful
in detecting the cat ok or doing the ultimate task which is which it is given ok.
Now, we use the same set of kernels across the entire image ok. So, this makes use of
the property of translation invariance which I was telling that the kernel may be a small
size kernel like 3 cross 3 or 5 cross 5 ok. The entire image may be thousands of pixels,
but the translation invariance property will ensure that the same kernel gets used in the
entire image ok. Now, why do we do this ok. So, another very important practical consideration
here is that as you can understand. So, let us say suppose you have a 200 cross 200 image
ok this is a very small size image this is probably the smallest size image you can get.
How many pixels are there? There is 40000 pixels ok, output layer also let us say there
is 40000 pixels. So, if you try to use a feed forward layer how many how many weights do
you have to use? You have to use 40000 cross 40000 weights this is a humongous number of
weights you can understand right. So, it is 160 million weights sorry 1600 million weights.
So, 1.6 billion weights 1.6 billion weights each weight is the number a floating point
number. So, this is a huge number ok. This many weights you cannot learn ok it is impossible
to learn this many weights and also the computation is going to be very very expensive ok. So,
instead what you do you use this convolutional kernels and the translation invariance property
of the image to maybe use maybe you have to use just 7 cross 7 which is 49 weight ok.
Maybe there is 1 for every channel. So, there may be many channels also. So, let us say
there are input 3 channels or maybe output 10 channels still it is 49 into 30. So, this
is a much smaller number of weights that you have to learn and store compared to this 1.6
billion weights for the same computation ok. And how is this possible? This is possible
because you are using the translation invariant property to use same weight across the entire
image by overlaying the kernel on different positions of the weight ok.
So, this is the idea this idea is illustrated here this I have already shown ok. So, in
real images you will typically have 3 channels of data ok. So, the left hand side here shows
the 3 channels of data RGB. So, red green and blue ok red green and blue channel ok and
output also will be in different channels ok. Now, here the output is being shown in
different channels ok. Maybe here this one is blue cyan yellow and black or maybe yeah
maybe this is cyan magenta yellow and black ok. So, output is in 4 channels ok. In practice
the output different output channels will capture the different first level features.
So, maybe this one is a horizontal edge detector this one may be a vertical edge detector this
one may be a fur texture detector or something like that ok. So, this is the whole idea ok.
Now what do you specify when you specify this convolutional layer when you are you know writing
the code right. So, you basically specify first the height and the width ok. So, height
and the width. So, this is 3 cross 3 this is 1 cross 3 and this is 3 cross 1 kernel
ok. So, this is the first thing ok. Now second thing you will specify is what is called the
padding ok. Now let me go into why you need padding. So, first you take a look at this
particular image. So, on the left hand side this is the input ok. In the middle is the
kernel and what we are doing is we are doing the simple basic convolution without any padding
without any stride to fill up the output ok. So, what happens first thing that you will
fill up is this left most position in the grid and that will give this output and so on and
so forth it will go. If you do that what you will see is that the first image that becomes
the center pixel is this particular image. So, the first center pixel is this image.
So, what happens this whole circle around it does not get to become a center pixel ok.
If you use the normal convolution ok. So, all the outer rim of the image does not get
to become the center pixel. As a result your output your input size was 5 cross 5 now it
has reduced to 3 cross 3 ok. So, in order to solve this problem what we do we introduce
a padding 0 padding ok. So, what is this 0 padding this. So, suppose your kernel size
is let us say 3 cross 3. So, very often you will see that in image processing people will
use odd size kernels ok that is for this particular reason that if you have a 3 cross 3 kernel
then you know that you are missing one full circle outside ok.
If you have a 5 cross 5 kernel as input you will be missing a 2 pixel wide circle outside
ok because your center pixel if you take if you come here let me erase this. If you have
a 5 cross 5 kernel basically this will be your first center pixel. So, all these guys
you will miss ok. So, you will miss 2 rows of this thing ok.
So, how do you do how do you solve this problem whatever you just pad you just assume that.
So, this is your actual input sorry this is your actual input image ok this portion is
your actual input image, but you assume that there are these 0 pixels all around it. How
many if your kernel size is 3 normally you would say 1 if your kernel size is 5 you will
assume 2 and so on and so forth ok. Now, if this is the case then you see your input original
input was also 5 cross 5 your output is also 5 cross 5. So, this kind of edge effect does
not matter ok. So, essentially if your kernel size is let us say k. So, here k is 3 you
do a padding of k minus 1 by 2 and you pad it generally with the 0 pixel ok. So, this
is padding. So, this is another thing that you specify when you define a convolutional
layer. What is the third thing that you specify when you define a convolutional layer that
is the stride ok. So, what is the stride? So, let me go here.
Now, you see earlier my first position was this from this the second position I moved
the receptive field by 1 pixel right I moved the receptive field by 1 pixel. Now, what
if you do not want to move the receptive field by 1 pixel you want to maybe take a larger
movement you may be want to move it by 2 pixels ok. What will happen every time you will move
it by 2 pixels ok. So, that is called the strided convolution ok. If you do that what
will happen is that you can let me just erase this you can see that ok. What will happen
is all your all your images or your output image even though you are using a padding
your output will be reduced by a particular size. So, in this particular case your input
was 5 cross 5, but now because you are using a stride of 2 your output has reduced by reduced
to 3 ok. So, the question is how do you do this calculation ok. The way to do this calculation
is suppose for the time being assume that you are not using any padding ok. If you are
not using any padding then what do you do basically if n is your image size and if f
is your kernel size f is for filter. So, kernel and filter are the same. So, if kernel slash
filter size is f ok. Then what will happen is the final output size will be n minus f
by stride ok. So, you can see if stride is 1 and suppose
your filter size is let us say 3 and let us say n is 7 ok. What will happen your output
size will be 5 ok. You can see this you can draw 7 cross 7 grid and see that this is indeed
the k ok. Now, if you use a stride of 2 what will happen is n minus f by 2 is basically
your 4 by 2 which is basically 2 plus 1. So, this becomes 3 ok. So, this was 4 plus 1 5
this is 2 plus 1 3 ok. So, you see the image size has now reduced a lot the output image
size ok. This is very very useful there are other ways to reduce the image size also I
will come to it in a minute, but this is very very useful if you think your input image
is of a very high very high resolution ok, but it does not have so much information ok.
So, you can skip some pixels basically. So, you do not need to process each and every
pixel as the center pixel ok. Now, with stride another thing comes which is that suppose
you try to take a stride of 3 what happens you see 7 minus 3 by 3 is a fractional number
it is 1.33 ok. So, this particular stride is not allowed.
So, if you do this particular stride your output will be something which is not understandable
because your output number of pixels is a fraction that does not make them ok. So, when
putting stride you have to be very careful as to put the stride such that using this
formula you are able to get a you know a whole sized output rather than just the this thing.
Now another thing is that suppose with this you are using a padding of 2 right. So, suppose
you are using a padding of 2 ok. What will happen if you use or let us say padding of
not 2 let us say in general padding of p ok. Then what will this formula become? This formula
see you are using padding means on both sides of the image you are adding this padding.
So, then your n becomes n plus 2 p ok. So, your formula will become you have we will
have to use this modified formula n plus 2 p minus f by stride plus 1 ok. So, you have
to specify the padding and the stride value such that this number is a whole number ok.
So, as I mentioned this is an example of a convolutional layer. So, what is there in
a convolutional layer? So, first of all the layer itself will have a image as input and
output will also be a image ok. It may not be an image that we understand many a time,
but it will be a in the form of a image ok. Now, the layer will have this filter. So,
let us say there is the 5 cross 5 cross 3 filter ok which means. So, remember if now
this part is called the depth ok. So, depth means the number of channels ok. So, the number
of input channels should match with the number of channels of the filter otherwise it is
an error ok. So, this is the first one ok. So, with this you will get a 28 cross 28 cross
1 output activation map ok. So, if you have a 32 cross 32 cross 3 image with a 5 cross
5 cross 3 filter you can do the calculation and you will get a 28 cross 28 cross 1 ok.
Now, this is one particular filter ok. Now, let us say you have another filter this is
blue colored filter this is green colored filter. So, this is showing the filter ok.
You can have another filter again you will get another activation map like this. So,
in general the number of filters number of output filters that you use that will create
the depth of the output channel ok. So, the number of output filters. So, in this case
if you use let us say so, if I use this 5 cross 5 cross 3 this filter with let us say
here there are 6 output channels ok. So, I am using 5 cross 5 cross 3 cross 3 3 cross
6 convolutional layer. Then your if your input is 32 cross 32 cross 3 your output will become
28 cross 28 cross 6 ok. Now, here we are not using any padding if we had used a proper
padding of 2 then the output will be 32 cross 32 ok. So, this we discussed.
Another important thing is what is called a pooling layer. So, suppose you want to reduce
the size of the image, but you do not want any learnable parameter because you see in
convolution there are learnable parameter, but instead you do not want any learnable
parameter ok. So, what you can do is you can use a max pooling or an average pooling layer.
So, usually people use max pooling layer. So, what happens? This is the 2 cross 2 max
pooling layer with stride 2. So, the pooling works just like convolution. So, here this
is the 2 cross 2 pooling. So, the kernel size is 2 cross 2, but instead of doing convolution
it will calculate the max from this and put it here and then it will stride by 2. So,
it will come here calculate the max here and put 5 here and so on and so forth ok. So,
that is what the pooling layer pooling layer is used mainly to shrink the size of the image
nothing more ok. So, what is now a convolutional network ok. So, it is basically a sequence
of convolution layers like this as I mentioned. This is the first input layer, then there
are some first input image, then there are some convolutional layers here, then the second
layer the first layer output and then here the second layer, second layer output here
and so on and so forth ok. So, this is a convolutional neural network this is how a convolutional
neural network works ok. It builds up the different feature representation one after
the other ok. So, this is an example of a convolutional neural network you see this is a car and now
I am only showing the outputs of the convolutional layers. So, this is an actual convolutional
neural network which has been used to classify this particular image and I am showing the
output of different convolutional layer at each stage. So, you can see maybe this particular
convolutional filter. So, here the input is of course, whatever the size of this image
is. So, maybe let us say 250 cross 250 cross 3. Here how many output channels are there
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 10 output channels are there ok. So, the so this is a convolutional
layer with 3 input channels and 10 output channels and whatever is the size of the convolutional
kernel that will come here ok. So, size of the convolutional kernel ok.
And these are showing some of the feature maps you can understand how the feature map
is basically getting created ok. You can see that different types of features are being
understood and then finally, when you have this feature map this. So, you typically use
a lot of pooling layer ok. Now, this has become a relatively low dimensional. So, this may
have 10 channels ok this may have 10 channels, but let us say input was 255 cross 255 and
you have used pooling 3 times ok. Every time let us say you have made it half the size let
us say or may be one third the size then this will become this divided by 3 to the power
the number of pooling layer that you have used which is a much lower number right.
So, if you have used 3 pooling layer it is basically 3 into 3 into 3 which is basically
I think 27 right. So, it will roughly be 10 numbers ok. So, output will be of size 10
into 10. Now, this 10 into 10 will be fed as an input for to a fully connected layer
or feed forward layer ok. Fully connected layer we have already discussed.
So, now you can see that your output is let us say size 5 and this 10 into 10 is basically
100. So, it in the end you are using a 100 cross 5 fully connected layer which requires
only 500 weights ok. So, this is the purpose of the pooling layer to reduce the size of
the image ok. So, this is the PyTorch implementation of maybe not the same, but a similar kind
of neural network. So, what you can see is this is you define a class just like earlier
you have seen and this 2D is the 2D convolution that I was just describing there is also 3D
convolution we will not get into that ok. So, and then there is Rayleigh. So, typically
after a convolution layer you apply a Rayleigh activation function to actually make it you
know do the thresholding. So, here you can see that after the thresholding.
So, this is before the thresholding and this layer is after the thresholding. So, after
the thresholding only the important things survive and the not so important things they
go away ok only the important feature survive ok. So, this is the first convolutional layer,
second convolutional layer and then pooling layer ok. Now of course, you have to define
the forward function you already know. So, the forward function is this. So, every time
you take the input x it is passed by the convolutional layer and then passed by the Rayleigh layer
to produce the output x. Then again that x is put into the convolutional
layer and the Rayleigh layer to get the output y and then you simply do a apply the pooling.
Now, the pooling generally does not have a learnable parameter ok, but this is the pooling
layer that you have ok. Now, this was so we are trying to implement this particular convolutional
neural network ok. Now, what we just showed is this convolution
convolution pooling block ok. So, this is one CCP block. So, that is what is implemented
in this class. Now, in this class we have 3 CCP blocks followed by a fully connected
block ok. So, this is basically describing this particular layer where there is a CCP
block. So, this is the first CCP block, this is the second CCP block, this is the third
CCP block and then there is a fully connected layer ok. And this is the design of a convolutional
neural network and this can this this can this is fairly good like this is this can
do a classification ok. So, this is the this is how the convolutional
neural network works or this is how you can design it ok. Now, let us go back. So, so
you can design many many different convolutional neural network architecture, but in the history
there have been some very important convolutional neural networks which people have designed
ok. And this revolution you can stay this is the. So, this is the deep learning revolution
you know deep learning. So, so this change the field of computer vision drastically drastically
influence the field of computer vision and it started around 2013 I would say ok. And
by 2017 we had some of the best models. I would say maybe instead of 2013 I would say
maybe 2012 it started and by 2017. So, in these 5 years some very good models were developed
and those are the models for many tasks they are very very useful ok. So, let us let us
see some of these models ok. So, before we go into the model I just want
to mention another thing which is this imaginate large scale visual recognition challenge. So,
this was a competition. So, it is called a challenge ok. So, this competition was held
yearly I do not know if it is still held, but at that time it was very very good competition
in the computer vision community ok. And you can see around 2011, 2011 the best accuracy.
So, so what is the challenge? The challenge is that you have images like the image that
I showed of a cat ok. And this image belongs to a particular class may be a cat chair,
airplane, fridge any of these ok. It could be a natural object it could be a artificial
man made object. So, there were about 1000 different classes ok. So, 1000 different objects
you have to classify ok. And now what you did is so, what the best approach
non deep learning approach at that time its accuracy was 25 percent ok. So, that was the
accuracy. So, like roughly you can sorry the error rate was 25 percent; that means, roughly
3 out of 4 images those methods were able to classify correctly yeah others it were
getting wrong ok. Now the first architecture that came in 2012 was called the Alex net
architecture. So, this was the deep learning architecture and will show the architecture
in a minute ok. This reduced the error from 25 to 16 percent ok. So, huge improvement ok.
The next very important improvement came which was this VGG net and Google net and it reduced
from error from 16 percent to 7 percent or 6 percent 6 to 7 percent ok. So, again nearly
made it half ok and 6 to 7 percent error is you can see it very less error ok. And then
finally, came the ResNet model which reduced the error from 6 to 7 percent let us say 7
percent to about 3 and a half percent ok again made it half ok.
So, these are the three steps from shallow to Alex net Alex net to VGG or Google net
and VGG or Google net to ResNet ok. In these years basically we could. So, this 3 percent
is better than human ok. So, if you give these images to humans they will make more than
3 percent error roughly 5 percent errors on this images in categorizing ok. So, the computer
was doing better than the human this is a very low error rate for this kind of a challenging
task ok. So, let us see what the first architecture was.
So, first architecture was this ok. So, you had the Alex net architecture you had the
convolutional layer then a max pool layer then a normalization layer. So, this normalization
layer is used to make the optimization faster ok. So, this is one block then the same block
repeated convolution max pool normalization. Then now there is no pooling required it is
already somewhat low. So, you have this three convolutional layer. So, you get more and
more features out of this ok and then finally, you have a max pool layer and then there were
three fully connected layer ok ok. So, this was basically the architecture and yeah. So,
you can see that yeah. So, the first layer was like this it had 96 11 cross 11 filters
applied at stride 4 ok. So, that was the this thing ok and this reduced to 16 percent as
I told ok ok. So, how many parameters for this layer around 35 k parameters ok 11 cross
11 cross 3 cross 96 ok ok. Now, so one thing which I did not mention. So, this 35 k and
if you see this whole architecture the total number of parameter was in million. So, I
think it was about 100 million 100 to 120 million something like that parameter ok and
the reason it was so high is because of these three fully connected layer ok. So, it was
all good, but still there were three fully connected layer ok and most of the parameters
were because of this fully connected layer. So, it was not a highly optimized architecture
ok ok. So, now, so these were some of the innovations
that they did. So, first is they used relu they use norm layer they use dropout ok they
use data augmentation etcetera ok ok. Now, so two problems was there with them first
is it was deep neural network, but it was relatively shallow only about 8 layer ok.
What VGG and Google net did is increase the depth to 19 and 22 layers respectively ok.
So, these are much more deeper network. Now, what does that mean? That means each layer
adds parameters. So, if you have a high number of parameters then the model size increases
the number of parameters increases and so your training complexity will also increase
because as you know if you have more have to learn more parameters then you have to
use more data to learn those more parameters ok. So, both problems go hand in hand ok.
So, this increase the size by. So, so almost you can say more than doubled actually the
size ok. So, how did they achieve this? So, the first thing they did is what is called
this small convolution and then composition of this. So, this is the main innovation of
this VGG filter which is that you use only 3 cross 3 filter ok stride 1 padding 1 ok
and you use 2 cross 2 max pool with stride 2 of course ok, but you see the architecture
many of the convolutional layers are one after the other ok.
What does this do? So, let us see ok. So, what this does is this increases what is called
the receptive field size of the convolution. So, so if you have 11 cross 11 convolution
filter ok or let us take this example that we have here. So, suppose you have 2 options
ok one is 7 cross 7 convolutional filter, other is 3 cross 3 convolutional filter. What
is the receptive field size of this? The receptive field size is 7 receptive field means at a
time how much of the image are you looking at ok that is the receptive field size ok.
And here you are having a receptive field size of 3 cross 3. So, at a time you are looking
at a 3 by 3 portion of the image. Now higher receptive fields are better because you have
more context whenever you are doing the convolution operation you are predicting for the center
pixel ok, but if you are looking at the neighboring only 3 pixels ok then you are looking at far
less information than if you can look at neighboring 7 cross 7 grid right. So, the receptive field
size higher is better, but as you increase the receptive field size what happens is your
number of weights increases ok. So, if the number of weights increases. So, here for
example, 7 cross 7 cross like so, so, so, before this I just want to mention that if
you use 3 3 cross 3 layer then you actually get a receptive field size of 7 cross 7 now
why is that ok. So, first let us see. So, this is let us say 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
9 let us say ok. Now let us say this is a center pixel ok. If you use a 3 cross 3 filter.
So, I am just showing a one dimensional representation here you can interpolate it is extrapolated
to 2 dimension. Your receptive field size is this much ok and now this is one output
of this filter ok 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7. Now let us say this is the center pixel that
it is outputting ok. Now you are again using another 3 cross 3 filter here. What is it
looking at? It is looking at this output pixel, this output pixel and this output pixel these
are linear transformations remember ok. Now how was this output pixel calculated? This
output pixel was calculated because you use this particular convolution overlay right.
So, for the first layer it was only looking at this ok, but now it is also looking at
this and this because here it is looking at this ok ok. So, what is this by using? So,
this is convolutional layer 1, this is convolutional layer 2 by using 2 convolutional layer you
have used increased. So, convolutional layer size is 3 this is 3 this is also 3 both convolutional
layer sizes are 3, but you have increased the effective receptive field to 5 you can
see this right. So, you have increased the effective receptive field to size 5 if you
use 3 layers of it you increase the effective receptive field to size 7 ok.
Now you see how many filter weights do you need? Here you need 7 square times c square.
So, this is 49 c square ok. Here how many do you need? Each layer each of the 3 layers
need 3 square many filter weights. So, 9 9 into 3 9 into 3 is how much 27. So, here you
need 49 c square parameters, here you need only 27 c square parameter. You are having
the same receptive field, but your number of parameters has decreased by about half
ok. So, this is the main innovation of this VGG net use smaller filters, but many filters
one after the other ok. So, here 2 at a time here 3 at a time ok. So, 2 at a time means
effectively you are using a 5 cross 5 filter, here effectively you are using a 7 cross 7
filter ok. So, this is the first thing that happened ok.
I am not going into the architecture of Google net too much, but what it did is it further
optimized it said that you do not have to use the same size filter. So, what VGG net
did this? It used the same size filter in each layer which is 3 cross 3. This guy says
for some of the channels you can use lower size filter, some of the channels you can
use higher size filter ok. And they came up with this inception module and this was even
more optimized than compared to the VGG module ok ok.
Now, this was the second leap. So, now, we are at 7 percent error rate right, 7 percent
error rate at what depth at depth of about 20 layers ok. Now, why were we not going
above 20 layers? Because of what is called a vanishing gradient problem. What does vanishing
gradient problem do? What it does is that if you have a extremely deep neural network
and then you have a loss at the end of it, what will happen is the initial layers of
the neural networks will have very small values of gradients and as you know these gradients
are what is used to train the neural network. So, it will become extremely difficult or
extremely slow to train the initial layers of a very deep neural network ok.
So, this problem was solved by what is called this residual network ok. So, how did they
solve this problem? They solve this problem. So, this is what happens ok. So, if you use
so what happens is then due to the vanishing gradient problem, what happens is that you
will see that the training error will reduce very very slowly. So, this is the 56 layer
neural network, this is the 20 layer neural network ok and x axis is the number of training
iterations. So, what will happen is you will see that the smaller number of layers is actually
doing better because it is learning faster. Ultimately this may go down more ok, but the
amount of time required for this 56 layer neural network to go down is so large that
for all practical purposes it was actually doing worse than the 20 layer neural network
ok. So, that is the key idea ok. So, what did
ResNet do? So, ResNet simply said each layer will not learn the feature representation.
It will learn what is called the residuals of feature representation ok, residuals of
feature representation. What does this mean? This means that suppose your for any given
layer suppose your input is x and your output feature is h of x. So, what people wanted?
They wanted that I will learn h of x. ResNet says no I do not want to learn h of x, I want
to learn this f of x which is h of x minus x and then how will I do computation? I will
simply says my output is f of x plus x ok. So, this is what the computation is. So,
instead of normal this neural network what the residual block does is it does what is
called this short circuit connection or residual connection ok. So, it connects the input to
the output and then predicts f x. So, if your neural network here is predicting the function
f x ok, this is actually outputting f x plus x ok and this is all it took and they could
using this ok, they could scale it to 152 layers and this is the architecture, the actual
architecture is not important. The idea is this that you can actually use these different
convolutional blocks. So, this is a one convolutional block followed by a skip connection, then
again another convolution block followed by a skip connection and so on and so forth till
you reach the output layer. So, what happens is your effective depth decreases a lot and
you are able to train this neural network very very fast ok.
So, you can you train till 152 layers and you got very high accuracy which is the close
to 97 98 percent right ok. So, ok. So, we will take a short maybe it 5 minute break here
and we will come back and I will describe some applications of these neural networks,
real world application ok.